juste je le dis aux téléspectateurs
qualité de son offre une qualité de
cheveux comme ça vous pouvez chercher
parmi tous les animateurs en europe n'a
pas voilà je vous le dis une qualité de
cheveux comme ça vous pouvez y aller que
ces magnifiques lui d'ici et d'ailleurs
je lance un hashtag venait toucher ma
qualité de cheveux j'étais le 23
décembre
vous êtes au travail votre enfant est à
la crèche et vous recevez un appel au
bout dit quoi on m'appelle pour me dire
de venir récupérer mon fils pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe et il m'explique
que monfils s'est fait mordre la voix
tremblante de la directrice adjointe au
vu de sa voix j'ai été compris qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
donc chacun travaille exactement il a
quinze mois en fait mon mari m'envoie
une photo de mon fils comme ça c'est
marie est resté sans voix fin on ne
savait pas quoi faire quoi dire pet est
en fait j'avais aucune réponse je n'ai
toujours pas de compte rendu
circonstancié je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé cette journée
j'ai demandé en une déclaration
d'accident je n'ai pas même en impact
psychologique de tout ça il ya quand
même un impact sur notre quotidien
'aujourd'hui qui fait que j'ai eu besoin
en fait de partager mon expérience et de
dire ce que je vivais seul mot qui
répète à longueur de journée ces bobos
voilà donc c'est pour vous dire moi
c'est pour vous dire si ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui quoi je gère bernard montiel
était en train de pleurer non mais c'est
vrai que j'avais vu comme ça mais je
vais vous dire ça on dirait qu'il avait
perdu un bon duvet non j'étais très ému
par les deux émissions ouais évidemment
c'est tous les deux jours oui c'est
connu
vous êtes l'avocat didier raoult et
c'est vrai que hier ça a été la fête de
didier raoult sur m6 a été
vous attendiez à un tel pugilat ouais
vraiment oui ouais vous aviez eu écho de
cette enquête non mais vous seriez
normal c'est normal moi je pense qu'il
manque un truc dans l'histoire c'est
quoi l'assassinât de kennedy
voilà pour veiller well as eu à un
moment donné on en est contre nous on
est là j'applique un truc à faire c'est
effectivement accusé raout d'avoir tué
kennedy
il n'en parle plus comme ça c'est réglé
ils ont accusé de tous les maux hier
n'ont pas de kennedy justement oui ça
c'est le seul truc c'est une vanne
commence a commencé ces abus sexuels
c'est un jeu que mon père a lancé lors
d'une visite d'un couple de voisins
donc c'est un
il voulait lancer un jeu sexuel entre 4
et cependant la commande couple c'est ça
donc nous on était à côté dans le salon
et on a commencé à entendre du bruit et
on est rentré dans le salon voilà et là
vous avez vu est en fait donc un de mes
frères qui a dit mais qu'est ce que vous
faites et mon père s'est levé et a dit
ben tu vas savoir quand on a 5 ans et
demi être capable de faire la différence
entre ce qui est bien et ce qui est mal
c'est très compliqué faux ça va vraiment
se mettre ça dans la tête
j'ai encore cette image en tête j'étais
dans le canapé avec ma game boy dans les
mains il me l'a arraché des mains et la
plier en deux comme ça et l'a jeté par
la fenêtre et ensuite il m'a il m'a
passé au dessus du ce
du cinquième étage d'où bear et avec lui
les policiers à paris dans le xvième
il est candidat des princes et des
princesses de lamoura pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas les princes et les
princesses de l'amour la semaine
dernière zoubir vous avez fait votre
arrivée dans les princes et les
princesses de l'amour c'est à la suite
de cette apparition que les soucis
aurait commencé votre hiérarchie vous
reproche notamment de ne pas les avoir
prévenus est ce que vous aviez prévenu
votre hiérarchie vous allez faire les
princes et les princesses de l'amour non
je n'ai pas prévenu fera voir que ça
fait un petit moment que déjà je suis en
rupture je suis fracturé avec avec
l'institution en général et avec ma
hiérarchie donc je les ai pas prévu mais
avait pas prévenus alors je crache pas
sur l'institution je parle de certains
comportements que j'ai vue opérées
auprès des personnes qui représente
l'institution
mais quand une femme vient déposer
plainte à 18h55 et que le plantier qui
finit à 19 heures il dit il va vient de
déposer plainte pour viol et le piatti
le platier il dit alors pas pu déposer
plainte pour viol alors pas pu se faire
violer un autre jour ça c'est des
comportements que je cautionne pas je
suis pas rentré pour sa fin c'est quoi
comme beaucoup à la folie mais oui moi
quand je suis rentré je suis rentré en
2017 dans la police quand je suis rentré
en plus je viens d'un endroit où ça aime
pas trop la police voilà donc moi je
n'ai pas d'à priori du tout devient
sartrouville
moi je suis rentré sans avis je viens
d'un endroit qui me pas la police je
rentre de la police ont fait mais c'est
moi c'est à dire que non non non
imposition de mots qui est quand même un
peu france faudra me laisser finir bon
aussi
[Musique]
mais voilà alors alors sa propre eau
marron vous allez nous avons encore dix
dans l'instant et ça ça avec l'uniforme
et tout ça passe pas du tout assez
désolant c'est pathétique désolant il a
d'autres qualités c'est dommage et qui
les exploitent en faisant ça et en
démystifiant et en donnant une image une
image lamentable de l'uniforme que je
leur ai fait venir vous dire vous pensez
que c'est terminé pour la police parce
qu'on mettra à l'essai s'éteindre envie
de vous faire dire et j'ai envie de
chercher autre chose
d'accord vous aurez à quoi tu as besoin
que j'avais surtout envie de kent nous
sommes dans direct bien sûr sur ces 8
c'est la centième d'à prendre ou à
laisser et oui vous ne rêvez pas c'est
bien le plateau de touche pas à mon
poste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
toi bachir est ce que ted j'ai été
victime de deux donné tellement de
harcèlement des mecs lourdaud ouais je
me souviens je dirait pas son nom parce
que je respecte infiniment sa femme
semblant votre nom d'un avocat célèbre
avec qui un jour j'ai déjeuné et j'ai
fait comme je suis très bien élevés pas
violent j'ai fait tout le déjeuner en
lui coin sans sa main entre mais j'en ai
ensuite quand je suis rentrée on va pas
l'auteur il y avait un hôtel à côté
jeudi un ballon mais je rentre bosser à
vsd je rentre à davézé ça me titille
j'appelle l'hôtel et je le redis ce que
vous avez une chambre réservée au nom de
et le nom de l'avocat on dit non et une
à gauche dit est-ce que vous avez une
chambre réservée au nom de morinie
batterie m'biwi et l'éditeur son éditeur
qui n'est plus à qui est décédé m'a
harcelé non pendant cinq mois en
bloquant dans sa bagnole me faisait me
faisais faisant venir dans son
appartement bloquant dans son
appartement j'ai dû sortir par une
fenêtre parce qu'ils avaient tous fermés
avec les mémoires alors mais c'est un
mec qui parle tout de suite ça fait
rigoler c'est vrai mais vous savez le
harcèlement il marque des deux côtés
siphat loue déjà d'en parler aujourd'hui
c'est pas facile mais j'en parle quand
même c'est nicolas lorsque je veux juste
vous dire c'est que le harcèlement il
existe partout et que à un moment donné
moi j'avais 18 ans je me suis cassé j'ai
pas de diplôme moi j'ai arrêté de
travailler et j'étais déjà arrêté
l'école à 16 ans j'ai flippé parce qu'un
monde et j'avais quand même mon premier
boulot mais j'ai décidé de partir après
il s'est trouvé que j'ai pas dit la
vérité à la chanteuse qui m'a dit de
toute façon été un imbécile et que je
réussirais pas dans ce métier mais on
s'est retrouvé très très vite à énergie
puisque deux ans après gta énergie et et
j'avais raconté cette histoire à mike
sweeney et ce qu'ils avaient fait marrer
mais se mutinent il l'avait dit ab
justement il ya un ogre aux patrons qui
est là nicolas pernikoff ça me fait
plaisir de te le présenter il va arriver
la personne a fait la gueule comme ça
parce qu'amélie est un abruti plaint
qu'on n'a pas cherché à comprendre
pourquoi je suis parti un peu comme un
voleur
papa pouvoir si ceux-ci cette saloperie
de virus mute d'année en année cyril on
va pas pouvoir concevoir une société qui
va rester confinés et où on va vivre
comme ça moi c'est ça c'est pas possible
à ce qu'on se dit patrick c'est que on
va confie néons var confiné on va d
confiné on va en fait on va et on a plus
de délai passé ça donc c'est plus
possible donc d'accous il ya quand même
on est quelques-uns à dire aux pouvoirs
publics notamment au président de dire
écoutez va falloir reconcevoir la
société et la civilisation sur des
nouvelles bases
parce qu'eux et ça je suis d'accord avec
vers ans qui l'a dit aujourd'hui
influencé par blanc caire et j'adhère
complètement
on ne peut pas arrêter les écoles parce
qu'il ya eu une alerte des
pédopsychiatres si on arrête les écoles
les enfants se désocialise et on a un
gros problème ça devient donc avons la
leyre étudiants aussi nous avons
l'alertent des pédopsychiatres nous
avons là l'herbe des psychiatres mais
nous avons jamais fait autant de suicide
chez les adolescents pour ce qui est du
samu de paris
d'accord laissez les centres médico
psychologiques sont débordés on a une
augmentation d'à peu près de 20% des
psychotropes faut qu'on fasse tenir les
gens c'est à dire c'est de la culture de
masse
je veux bien qu'on nomme des supers
scientifique bardé de diplômes que je
respecte par dessus tout qui sont
formidables
le problème c'est qu'on est sûr de la
gestion de masse on est là on est sur le
fait qu'on a une population qui est en
souffrance que là on en oublie vous
savez le principal fléau tout ça c'est
la solitude
[Musique]